- Sometimes you gotta
eat neatly, you know,
you gotta put on bibs.
(rock music)
- Someone dared us to
do this Ramen Challenge.
- I think that we have
great team chemistry.
- I'm gonna kill this (expletive).
- I'm pretty sure I'm gonna throw up.
(laughing)
You're not tall enough
for this, I don't think.
(laughs)
- You got good form, man.
- Nope, wrong way, upside
down. Those are upside down.
- [Voiceover] Three, two, one, go.
(laughing)
- Mm, mm. I'm feeling good, man.
- Okay, get some ramen.
(stuttering)
(laughing)
(inaudible)
- We love ramen.
(laughs)
(cameraman responds inaudibly)
- Less portions, please.
(laughing)
- You have to even out the chopsticks
because you're, like,
stabbing me in the throat.
- Oh, I just got it on my hand.
- Mm hmm.
- There's, like, hair in my mouth.
(laughing)
- Perfect. Oh, you got that shit.
Do that.
(grunts)
- Oh, (expletive).
- Did I get it?
- Yeah, you got it.
- Oh, it's on it.
(inaudible)
- It's cold.
- Yeah, this is chicken. Hold on.
- Oh.
- Stay where you are, stay where you are.
- Thank you.
(inaudible)
That's fantastic, man. Thank you.
What a gentleman.
- Is it actually pouring some broth?
- Tip the spoon.
(slurps)
Mm hmm.
- I fell like I did that well.
- You're going good.
- There's too many noodles.
(laughs)
- It's too much noodles?
- This is crazy.
- Oh, (expletive).
(laughs)
Too much, too much.
- [Voiceover] Too much? Keep going.
- You're waterboarding me.
(speaks inaudibly)
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] And chopsticks down.
- Ah.
(ding)
(chewing)
- [Voiceover] Cut.
(groans)
(ding)
- You actually did really good.
- Yeah?
(ding)
(pops)
- I think I did bad.
Probably, Leo did really good.
I mean, he had a hard
time finding the egg,
but, I mean, he followed
the directions really well.
- The challenge is in account for the fact
that I laugh every, like, five seconds.
- It's literally dripping
off of your beard right now.
- I know. It's, like, so good.
- We bonded a lot over this challenge.
- How come you never got coffee, bro?
(high five)
- Ramen Challenge!
- There we go.
(squeaking)